if my home's heals I think the Chiefs
might win but right now pick a team bro
I'm picking evils right I'm going Chiefs
let's go Mahomes is an advantage for the
Chiefs that they have great tight end
play when you have a strong defensive
line yeah it is but if you remember the
Super Bowl they lost to the Bucks that
was the main issue is Mahomes could not
throw the ball he didn't have time to
throw the ball now the offensive line of
the Chiefs isn't as beat up as it was
back then but the defensive line of the
Eagles is better unless Mahomes is 100
just gonna be too much if he can run
around and create like evade sacks and
create time he can find guys downfield
whatever I think they could win and he
healed crazy quick one week so maybe two
weeks even with this game is going to be
enough but again he would be just like
defying all the odds because you're not
supposed to heal that quickly Philly's
taking it I think easy they have I hate
saying they say the best roster in the
league Run game is crazy game is crazy
offensive line crazy defensive line
crazy and that's what they always say
you win games